welcome to this video playing in
pictorial from France gap this guy has
the name in that Ryan is to keep
forgetting it though when you are lipid
each international marseille he does not
have that I'm tool in them okay hmm can
I do something else yeah well this is
what I nobody do when I get to this
position which is not often yeah
interesting okay Black is just
retreating them hmm it's not damaging my
pawn structure it looks so it looks
slightly weird to have the knight on c6
oh it's a somewhat strange setup but ok
but I guess certainly not in a terrible
shape ok I don't want to help him with
trade so going to put the bishop on g3
and here again keep pieces on the board
yeah i was thinking about that but i
don't really don't really think it is
that great i get something to eat 595 is
a slightly annoying piece for him i
believe
yeah okay light coming to the fore gee I
don't know maybe I should have actually
made sure that there is nothing that my
pawn structure isn't damaged
okay and is threatening to take on c3
and play night if force is really a
strategic TG threat here
I bishop h4 as possible not sure about
the whole thing setting up a counter
pinned in a way i'm unsure i don't want
that i'm not sure where to go i'd
actually want to contest the e4 square
so nature so like a three and back away
392 d6 does knight c6 this is not on the
place 94 I will play a three or Bishop
you want I wasn't sure about it it both
seems viable yeah Knight to c6 is not
leading to any of two anything
covering Sofia the position is totally
ok for me nothing nothing terrible
happening but I'm definitely not better
or anything it was a quite interesting
way to play ok I cannot take c5 I can
take e 4 and 92 though is this the way
to go or is there some better idea night
somewhere I can take an idea for this
was my original idea i think i should do
it I Scott D Phi of him ok I can take
here actually i have this Knight takes
e4 trick which I didn't see initially be
takes Knight takes e4 and my you want
clean is attacking the night ok it's
reacting to that ok ok there's no reason
not to take this want to now
yeah 82 hangs I got everything
everything nicely protected x-ray if you
take see I can I should maybe go for
some counter tech here like Quincy for
Queen g6 those kind of things do
something about this offside pieces okay
is there some way to counter check take
e for take a--take d5 techie for takes
rook the seven this kind of business
getting counterplay or take before
immediately then rocky seven-4
counterplay ice queen be too well it's
not really leading to much okay take
that anyway taking d 5 i'm not sure
about all that black's pieces they are
not really well coordinated I mean okay
I'm not saying that my pieces are
fantastically coordinated but I'm really
unsure how is he protecting d5 look c5
there is before that's not it
this whole Queen B to a to business is
not helping blacks black harmony there
may be stuff like Roxy to trying to be
active I was thinking before it's just
why not what is what what is wrong about
before what is what is wrong about it I
don't see it okay this stuff okay time
morning
check i only had forty-five seconds is
not quite enough to check to get to a
proper assessment or such a position
reigning queen we're booked via exactly
look back he takes takes b6 always take
b6 here okay ah what a shame
yeah that's one of those cases where you
can totally sure that the computer shows
you afterwards how you could have gotten
a really good position but I didn't see
anything I didn't see anything in the
game would be very very strange if there
wasn't something with black being a
total disharmony but I needed to play
something like this this before I mean
there was no time
check
check
nah 23 maybe but others can be one
no I mean okay all right this precise
the position the thymus yeah so how do i
punish him for this nonsense let's look
at it takes takes Queen d7 yeah wyd wins
this is no surprise but what did I what
did I overlooked look a oneness
Winningham and there there must be
something I mean I wasn't I was just
thinking okay let's take this thing on a
five so look a one wins young Queen here
I take with check check so it totally
falls apart and Queenie for yeah that's
the big point I get this and I'm
threatened and covering that that is the
point yeah this is just a flat flat win
for nothing 22 pounds for no
compensation yeah there must it wasn't
simply on that that he can misplace all
its pieces and there's no punishment for
that I mean did this this is rook c6 and
so on it's clear that's not that's not
working but I didn't see it I didn't see
how this is this is clearly reeking okay
f5 is also winning f5 f6 with the
winning a check that's even stronger
according to the comp I mean this is
just just terrible but I simply didn't
simply didn't see it ok and here of
course it was some I can take I can
still go could we ecig shake and take
take with the Queen on g6 check now okay
well here it's not really g3 is still
okay I exactly here g3i because he has
no square for the rook okay that was
difficult to lose it but but I still has
still managed no no cable next one
thanks for watching